all right more on this now let's bring
in texas senator john cornyn senator
cornyn it's good to see you this
afternoon i wanted to ask you first of
all your thoughts on this news the dhs
itself
just confirmed that many of these
haitian migrants are being released on
their own recognizance into the united
states
well unfortunately that is consistent
with the policy that has encouraged 1.2
million migrants to come to our borders
since joe biden became president it's
entirely inconsistent with what they
said they were going to do with the
haitian migrants in del rio which is
repatriate them to
to haiti
so
unfortunately this is the same mistake
they have made from the very beginning
that they tell they say one thing and
they do another but these folks and the
human smugglers who smuggle them into
the united states and make a lot of
money doing it
are watching what they're doing and not
listening to what they're saying if i
could just read from the dhs press
release that went out a short time ago
it says individuals and this talk about
the haitians who are not immediately
repatriated are either placed in
alternatives to detention detained in an
ice facility or released with a legal
document either a notice to appear in
court or a notice to report to an ice
office for further immigration
processing are you concerned senator
that like we have seen so many times in
the past that if some of these migrants
who are released in the united states
just have a piece of paper saying you
should go see an ice officer or there's
a notice to appear that they'll just
blend into society and we'll never hear
from them again
well this is a designed to fail um it
will fail to deter
not just the 15 000 haitians that we've
seen in del rio but the next wave of
migrants who come in because the
administration simply doesn't
acknowledge that what we have here is a
flawed policy which provides a magnet
for
people to continue to come in the
country because they know
they can simply blend into the great
american landscape this is
what has been called catch and release
catch and release does not deter people
from coming it simply encourages more to
come president biden was asked about the
situation at the southern border
yesterday when he was in new york at the
united nations let's just watch this
quick exchange with a member of the u.s
press pool
mr president what's your reaction to the
images coming from the southern border
get it under control
under control or you have it under
control we will get it under
the president said we will get it under
control but what we seem to see here
senator is a litany of successive crises
if it's not uh migrants coming in from
the northern triangle it's people coming
in from venezuela or now it's people
coming in who were in haiti at one point
along their journey we understand that
there's a group of some 20 000 more in
colombia who are looking at what's going
on in the border in del rio and say wow
now is the time to come
well what i worry about is the
definition of the biden administration
about having things under control is
very different from what i
what i would say when somebody asked me
is our border under control our border
is not in control if what they mean
they're they're in control they're
processing people into the united states
continuing the same policies that served
as a huge magnet uh to this humanitarian
crisis there will be another one right
behind the haitian
wave and it's all because joe biden and
his administration either don't care
or they don't know how to fix it but
i've got a bipartisan bill with senator
cinema
also supported by democrats and
republicans in the house that would help
stop the flow but so far they've shown
no interest yeah you know
and obviously kirsten cinema the senator
from arizona has got a big stake in this
as well given what's going on in in her
state in terms of not interested brendan
judd who's the president of the national
border patrol council was on fox earlier
today he says that his union warned dhs
in june back in june that something like
this might happen listen to what he said
the response was from dhs
not only did they ignore us they said
that they had more efficient ways to
deal with this and now we had at the at
the top of this we had 14
872 people under that bridge if that's
efficient then our government is broken
so let me get your thoughts on that if
what we see there on the left-hand side
of our screen is that a more efficient
way of dealing with mass migration
no
mr judd knows what he's talking about
and he is a he's an expert on these
matters and the administration would do
well to listen to him and uh he's also
of the opinion that this catch and
release system is simply an incentive
for people to continue to come look
these these migrants pay thousands of
dollars to human smugglers to bring them
into the united states obviously they
want to come to the united states but if
there's no deterrence uh no enforcement
of our immigration laws uh then they're
going to keep coming and the numbers are
going to just get worse
now alejandro mayorkas the secretary of
dhs was on the hill yesterday subjected
to some withering criticism and
questioning from senator ron johnson of
wisconsin let's listen to this exchange
i'll get get you on the other side
how many people have been returned
how many people are being detained how
many people have been dispersed to all
points around america
uh senator i would be pleased to provide
you with that debt i want them now
why don't you have that information now
uh senator i do not have that debt why
not
why don't you add that basic information
now certainly dhs has got a lot of
information senator uh not the least of
which is that uh in the fiscal year uh
2020 2021 which comes to a close on the
30th 30th of this month so far 1.5
million people have come across the
border illegally we still have one month
to go so that number could rise
substantially
do you is is
i mean i don't mean to be
critical here but is the secretary just
gaslighting america
yeah i think that's one way to put it uh
he either doesn't know which i would
think would be malpractice on his part
or he does know and simply doesn't want
to share it with members of congress
doing oversight or the american people
because it's bad news
and the worst part of this is if you
make the same mistakes over and over
again you're going to get the same
result and we've seen what's happened
with joe biden's failed border policies
for the first eight months he's been in
office and i think we can expect this to
continue into the future until uh until
he
or congress is able to do something
about it
now we saw texas governor greg abbott on
the border right there at that bridge
the other day talking about what texas
has had to do to step in
and fill the gap that the federal
government is not filling here's part of
what the governor said
the body administration
is a man-made disaster
of inhumanity of epic proportions it
must end it must end immediately and the
way to end it is by the administration
stepping up and finally enforcing the
immigration laws of the united states of
america now the federal government has
got sold jurisdiction for handling
immigration issues but the state of
texas your state senator has had to step
in here divert dps resources
it's had to put boots on the ground
there to stop this this problem we
actually saw dps officers form a wall
out of cars to stop migrants from coming
across the rio grande this is obviously
taking a big toll in terms of time money
and man and woman power
away from what the state needs to do
elsewhere
well john we're ground zero we have 1200
miles of common border with mexico if
the federal government isn't going to do
the job then our state leaders governor
abbott and other have no choice but to
do it themselves yeah this is this is a
problem uh of huge magnitude you look at
our border communities that depend on
cross-border trade and yeah and tourism
they're being devastated they're being
overrun by these huge numbers um senator
i'm sorry i i don't mean to interrupt
but we we need to jump out of this and
go to the white house i'm steve ducey
i'm brian killman and i'm ainsley
earhardt and click here to subscribe to
the fox news youtube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis